books and authors
booktv.org
next roya hakakian talks about the 1992
killing of four iranian kurdish
dissidents in germany and the trial that
followed
this is about 45 minutes
good evening
what a lovely place i think this was
gertrude stein's concept that they
brought to life here at this bookstore
books and books in miami my god cafe and
restaurant and courtyard
magnificent
thank you so much for having me this is
an absolute pleasure
to be here in this wonderful beautiful
place
so
this will not shock you because you
don't know me but i started out as a
poet
and the idea of writing about a crime
is the farthest thing that has ever been
from my mind
i
have never
pictured myself
in any way shape or form interested in
guns blood dead bodies
and i've tried to stay away from them
for as long as i can and as far as i can
and usually even when we're watching tv
at home and someone draws out a gun i'm
the first person to reach for the remote
control and change the channel
so this won't surprise you but the fact
that i ended up writing about an
assassination was a complete shocker
uh to me
and
the way this
fell into my lap so to speak
was that
as it was mentioned earlier in the
introduction
this political assassination that i
wrote about
took place in september of 1992 in
berlin germany at a restaurant and
two gunmen one with a machine gun the
other with a handgun walked into the
restaurant
and
started shooting at the eight guests who
had gathered
over a dinner party that night
and shot them all
four died died instantly and the other
four survived now of the four survivors
one ended up being my houseguest
for several weeks
and
i knew very little about him he was
a friend of a friend who was coming
through town in new haven connecticut
where i live
and
and as i was
trying to cook dinner in the evenings
keeping him company you know
trying to be a good host i would be
chopping onions and he would be
sitting across from me trying to help
and
making conversation and um
and i made the mistake of once asking so
what happened to you in september of
1992.
and then the rest was history just like
shahir zod
he would tell me a new installment of
what had happened um not simply the
night of the murder
which
to to many minds might seem as the most
interesting or the most intriguing part
of the story
but actually what i found most fabulous
and most
engrossing
was the way in which
the investigation
and everything else
unraveled so
i would be making my dinner and you know
doing going about my own
thing in the kitchen and he would be
giving me the next day within the
investigation the next day the next day
until he came up to the trial and by the
time he reached a trial which which is
about a year into his storytelling i
thought that i should take a trip to
berlin germany and visit other people
so um
of course i i set all of this up to say
that when you have
a writer who has started out as a poet
and is generally very squeamish around
anything
having to do with blood then
you get a story you get a crime story
told in a way that few crime stories are
told which is that against everybody's
advice
rather than
talking about delaying the crime so the
readers would be interested in
reading the story so they get to the
gruesome crime you know halfway through
the book or two-thirds down in the book
i
being as squeamish as i am i get rid of
it in the first five minutes
of the book and say
you know let's move on now you know uh
and and i hope um if and when you do
decide to read the book you agree that
in a way this was
not only a poet's look into a crime but
also
a woman's look at a very very
male-dominated macho
story and the reason i call it a
male-dominated macho story is because
the killers were men the people who died
were men all the people who subsequently
get involved were men and
and so i i guess it was
um
for me to try to look at this very very
intriguing story and say
how would i look at this what would i
find interesting in this and
what what is it
that would make
such a gruesome story
really intriguing for all readers
from a
perfectly new perspective or a
completely
let's say revolutionary perspective and
um and you'll tell me if i have achieved
at
creating that sort of perspective so
um so that's how that's how it goes i
mean i i get rid of the crime and what i
follow through with um pretty diligently
because after i took my
trip to berlin uh the subsequent
characters that i met
um
uh
one seemed to be more
intriguing than the other and that
wasn't because
any one of these heroes any one of these
survivors
investigators
uh where in any shape or form perfect
people but but rather that
in their imperfection
in their fallibility
they all
together contributed
to
bringing about a very very
historic
trial
and verdict
which by
the accounts that i've received from
several legal historians
happens to be the one of the most
important trials in the history of
europe in the 20th century
and and you're probably just as
surprised as i am
why none of us heard about it well
that's precisely why i decided to write
about it because it seemed like a very
very important story that had gone
untold
so you know that the knight you know
that there are eight people sitting
two people walk in one person stands
guard
four people get
shot and die immediately and um four
others survive now
um the first person
who was in my kitchen talking to me was
one of these four survivors his name was
parvis p-a-r-v-i-c
and
and
and
of of the very first first questions
that i asked them was
this
so what did you do when you first got
home
it may not seem a very
smart question to many of you but it was
really curious to me
what if
one of us in this room survives
such an atrocious crime
and
the police comes we go to the
headquarters of the police we get
interrogated whatever it is that they do
fingerprint i don't know
and then it's all over and several hours
later in his case 4 5 am
and now you're all alone and you have to
go back
to your life as usual you have to go
back to your
own space your own apartment
what is that like so that was one of the
very first questions that i asked them i
said so what happened to you
the next morning what happened to you
when
when you were done and they said you can
now go home
and so he
um i will read a very short passage from
um from the moment he arrives home and
and what are his thoughts and then
follow through
with some of the other characters
they're after
these microphones are wilting
it's okay okay
calls
okay sorry about that
i broke the microphone
thank you
calls all he wanted to do was to make
calls he pays the perimeter of the
apartment from his living room couch
across the television set where the news
was on to the balcony for air to the
telephone on his bedroom desk to the
stove in the kitchen where he was
boiling water for tea over and over
again
his morning routine had vanished
the thought of eating or going to bed
did not enter his mind he dialed his
secretary
i won't be in today he told her and when
asked why he broke into an endless sob
were you robbed
is your mother dead is your daughter
missing
came the secretary's frantic questions
all he would say to her was
turn on the news
he took a shower under the rushing water
he stood with his eyes wide open if he
closed them the image of an extended arm
in a black leather sleeve would plague
his mind it was not until the streaming
water struck his body
that he felt the aching in his right
cheek and temple and remembered the blow
to his right side when he fell off his
chair at the restaurant
the age of real-time news had not dawned
and the reporters were not yet looking
for him on an ordinary morning he would
have reveled in the peace
but against the uproar within him
this quiet was the anticitis to peace
he returned to his desk and made another
call it was to a friend on the editorial
board of a leading daily
hello there this is parveez
hey there parves
the voice replied softly modifying the
last syllable of the name as parveez had
told him to
think of paris he told germans who had
trouble remembering his name
then add a v and the r and voila you've
got me
a slight mispronunciation he figured was
a small sacrifice for the sake of good
mnemonic
he crafted a single sentence to distill
the ordeal for the busy journalist
i was there at the restaurant at myknows
where the four men died last night
i heard let's have coffee one of these
days to talk it over today is insane
parveez taking taken aback by the
lukewarm reply was forming his next
sentence when the reporter excused
himself and rushed off
the reporter's quick dismissal caused
the wave of panic in him
for years he had carefully collected
journalists the way others collect
stamps
in their company the raccoon tour
impervies found a captive audience
spinning tail was a skill he had been
perfecting since childhood when he and
his friends who could not afford to go
to the movies pulled their allowances
together to buy a single ticket for an
emissary to see then recount a 90-minute
film over a span of hours so elaborately
that the real film if the others ever
did get to see it invariably fell short
of its description
journalists had always been parvisa's
most formal formidable allies years ago
after his visa had expired the same
editorial writer had saved him from
deportation but by writing his scathing
piece on germany's repressive
immigration policy but now
to whom could he turn now
as he brooded the telephone rang the
same voice filled in the receiver once
more
i'm sorry parvez
it took me a bit to register what you
said did you say you yourself were at
the restaurant last night
that's what i said
then we must talk instantly
so the two of them get together and he
interviews
parvis and writes up an editorial that
runs
the very same day in in the paper
um
and what what becomes really the thrust
of this
murder in the beginning say in september
october november of 1992 when it had
happened was whodunnit
there were there were on one hand
the exiled iranians who
who had their own opinion
there were
politicians and uh
and journalists who had um who were
circulating other possibilities and and
so there were a slew of ideas that were
kind of circulating around and uh
and um that was sort of the dominant
theme of the first three months however
very quickly thereafter
a very wonderful
um and and one of the most important and
most intriguing characters in this book
um
got assigned to the case a a prosecutor
discovers that
um the truth is
actually well i don't want to kill the
plot line for you but but he sides with
one possibility within within the slew
of theories that are
um swirling around that this is a
governmental sponsored
series of terrorist acts and
assassinations
and um so after his assignment to the
case the story shifts from being
kind of a whodunit to
will they do the right thing will the
people who
who have power will the people who
who can and have the ability to
bring justice to these victims
do what is expected of them
and act nobly and
and and do what um really the laws
um
clearly mandated them to do
um and so that leads to a trial which
opens within a year after the
assassinations
and a
four nearly four-year proceedings a
very dramatic
four-year courtroom uh proceedings that
finally leads to
a historic verdict
in april of 1997.
now
it was mentioned during the
introductions that
there are a confluence of characters in
this book
and that was part of the
challenges of putting this book together
um if i had fictionalized it i would
have easily
eliminated at least
20 of them and easily stuck to
the
my leading man who would have been the
prosecutor and the investigator and then
done away with everyone else and
and endowed him with all the great
qualities and abilities to
um to save the day which eventually he
does but not by himself
um however it was a piece of non-fiction
and
and i think
and i believed um
again despite all the advice that i was
receiving that rather than simplifying
the story or fictionalizing the story
um
readers
are very sophisticated sophisticated
nowadays they've read so much that they
can actually manage a multi-character
story and they can keep track of
numerous characters going in and out and
they don't need a singular hero
certainly not in the 21st century we
have given up a lot of our old myths and
whatever dreams we once had about
singular heroes saving today and we
understand that a confluence of
characters personalities uh events
uh need to come together in order for a
great great triumph to take place um so
the the great i suppose um uh character
of this book in a way becomes the the
its own plotline and the narrative
itself
um
and what um
what i hope you you will find is that
the unraveling of events
take a life of their own and
that becomes the
through line which we follow
um
in
when i took my first trip to berlin to
assess and see whether the other angles
of this were as appealing as
the one i had discovered in my own
kitchen i ran into the widow of one of
the four men who had died in the
restaurant that night and
um
and immediately after she opened the um
her door to me and i entered the
apartment she asked me where in the
united states i lived and i said at the
time i lived in new york and i said that
i was coming from new york and
she said
um
that the
this was practically the third sentence
out of her mouth that she wished she had
been here on
on 9 11
and i said
why and she said because
she too had lost a loved one her husband
in a september
september on september 17
about 10 years earlier
and she knew exactly what
the widows
who had lost their husbands
and she also had a daughter
and the children who had lost their
fathers were going through
and she wished she had been here after 9
11 she'd been in new york after 9 11
because she thought that all the all the
widows all the people like her
um women
should
come together and create a network
of
um
widows who had suffered through an act
of terrorism
because it knew no
national boundaries that this was sort
of a global problem
that um had afflicted her as much as any
american woman here in the states and
and it was in listening to her
that i really decided
that the story
the value of the story was beyond
um
the perimeters in which i was thinking
about it initially that that there was
something to what she was saying that
something about these
acts of crime these particular acts of
crime which had been
sponsored by
radical ideologies in this case um the
government of iran
bonded all of the victims regardless of
where they came from and and i found
that extremely moving and and it was
the moment
that really
um
gave me the incentive gate you know
made me resolute about wanting to write
this book so
um
last but not least i want to introduce
her to you
and have you
listened to her frustrations
and experience
because we are just coming out of the
10th anniversary of 9 11
and i think much of what she told me in
in the her griefing process and all
reminded me of the stuff that i was
hearing
um
being played on radio and television in
the past few weeks
so her name is shore
s-h-o-h-r-e-h
there are a lot of h's there but
but mostly we
simplify it by saying sure she
did she and her husband had a daughter
together
and her name is sarah
and
i refer to
sarah and
the daughter of parvis who
about you know
who appeared in the previous section and
her name is salome so you're going to
hear
about two children two girls who are
almost the same age a mom
and then parivis whom you've already met
now something very interesting that that
happens is that while
parvee is a survivor is trying to
gather documents
try to get the court to see
the truth about the case try to
feed the proper information to all the
journalists from here and there
in the midst of all this and god knows
you know recovering from the trauma that
he has experienced
um his 10 year old daughter is having
fainting spells
and
and he just and
nobody seems to at least for the first
few weeks be able to diagnose uh why why
she's having these so
so he um takes her to the doctor and and
we open up
in the doctor's waiting room
under the glare of the fluorescent
lights in the exam room
parvis waited
sometimes kissing sometimes stroking the
hand of his daughter salome
he looked she looked even more frail in
the hospital gown
he felt restless on behalf of his
aspiring 12 year old dancer who had been
told to remain still till the doctor
returned
two fainting spells confounding
confounding several internists and
pediatricians had forced the daughter
and daughter the father and daughter to
see a cardiologist
two fainting spells on her part and a
heap of guilt on the father's part
ever since the morning after of the
murders
parvis had tried to keep her away from
the fallout his first phone call had
been to his ex-wife to try to shield
salome from the news
before picking her up from her on
tuesdays their weekly day their weekdays
together he combed through the apartment
to hide all signs of the case from view
photos letters phones phone messages
newspaper clippings
but the more he hid the more she wanted
to know
how did it happen dad
how many were there
did you did anyone hit you
they came they shot they left nothing
happened to me nothing at all he would
say
wishing to move on
but her questions continued
did you have blood on you did you scream
did you cry did you cry after were you
scared are you scared
the depth of her curiosity astounded him
once he yelled enough
and she stopped asking but he knew she
had not stopped thinking the same
thoughts
the dream of becoming a dancer had
turned her into a reluctant eater and so
he designed intricate plants for her
meals
instead of an elaborate dinner he lined
up an epicure's array of tiny appetizers
which he paraded before his willowy
ballerina at intervals
in the small tidy apartment brimming
with music the father surrendering to
the daughter's whims
had agreed to be a dance student in the
tutelage of his dimunitive coach
though tone deaf and hopelessly
uncoordinated
his performances were memorable what he
lacked in talent
he compensated for in wit
when he failed to remember his steps he
limped cross-eyed across the floor
as he dragged the foot he greeted an
imaginary audience not with gutentag
german for good day but with his own
persian german
concoction guzbatag or fart on your day
nothing like a bit of vulgarity to bond
a part-time father with his
pre-adolescent child
what he could not fathom was that joy
however abundant was no substitute for
safety which she no longer felt in his
presence
nor could he imagine her days in school
among classmates who treated her like a
sensation
only some of the questions she asked
were her own the rest were once the
children mocking her father as the
superhero and the nightly news
incessantly badgered her with while she
stared into their faces and fought back
tears
when the first fainting smell spell came
over salome he thought she had starved
herself
but when she fainted on a full stomach
he blamed himself and his complicated
life for his daughter's malady
the cardiologist returned to the exam
room without a definitive diagnosis and
advised that he observed her closely for
a few days
he had tried hard to keep her out of her
out of his own gloomy world lest the
killers or the mere idea of them rob her
of a happy childhood
but now it seemed that the vacuum he had
surrounded her with was robbing her of
breath
unlike salome
sarah
wanted to know nothing
now the difference is that salome's
father had survived and sarah's father
had died
in november she had asked shore
where her father was exactly now and if
he was in pain
in december she had asked if she could
buy him christmas gifts and leave them
under the tree until he returned
in february she had asked if her mother
intended to marry another man and if so
if he was going to move in with them
by march
she no longer asked
if she heard the name of the restaurant
on the radio she rushed to turn it off
if she recognized the faces of family or
friends on television she walked out of
the living room
to help sarah
and her mother cope with the husband's
loss
sure's parents had moved in with the
daughter with with the two of them for a
few weeks
their presence strengthened the two of
them though sure could not tell them
that it did
sentences failed her
what she had in abundance was tears her
parents stared at her over breakfast and
waited in vain for her to form a
sentence as simple as
how did you sleep
her senses failed her
she rarely felt hunger she barely tasted
the perfunctory bites she took in front
of them to assure them of her appetite
to reassure them of her appetite
her parents a government clerk and
housewife had led serene and predictable
lives
it was the security of their life that
had given shore the courage to rebel
against them go off to europe
and marry a rebellious man just just
like herself
but she wondered
would sarah not have been better off
with a pair of ordinary parents for life
than a pair of extraordinary ones for
only a time
all day she turned these
she turned these thoughts over in her
mind's kiln blazing with anger
to hell with his extraordinariness and
every bit of his brilliance
she would mumble to herself
her husband enraged her now
stick with me and you'll be famous like
you deserve to be he had promised her
when
on the first night that they had met
had death been his path to fame
she shouted in her head
once again he had abandoned them all
through her pregnancy and delivery she
had been alone remembering his absence
she would grow more and more furious
each day she wonder if it had been a
warning to prepare her to prepare her to
raise their child alone reason had
abandoned her she no longer thought of
him or his absence as involuntary he had
left him yet again
the thought came to her to her when she
played their own their old family movies
she spent one night watching reels of
film to find him only once and only for
a few seconds walking with her along the
racetrack where sarah ran her first
competition
the footage so keenly resembled their
lives now as if through them her husband
had sketched their future everyone moved
posed smiled following his instructions
but he their director was invisible his
vision filled the screen
yet he would not be seen
just like now
thank you for listening
i have been told by the wonderful people
who are running this establishment and
cameras that you ought to wait for the
microphones to reach you before you ask
your questions
um what is the significance of the
turquoise palace i i i didn't i haven't
read the book yet so i'm not familiar
with it
what is the
significance of turquoise palace um
there is a moment i'd like to think it's
a
exciting moment within the trial
where a key witness
somebody no one knew even existed
shows up
and he becomes sort of the smoking gun
for the attorneys in the trial
and
it is during a dialogue during a q a
that's being conducted
on the stand that you will know the
answer to your mystery
[Music]
yes please
given your background uh
as a poet i wonder if you have ever
written
non-fiction prior to this
and if not
did you have
any thought
about
fictionalizing it
and telling a
slightly different story
in that manner
well this is a work of nonfiction as it
stands
and my previous work in english was a
memoir
and
and actually after i
pieced this together i decided that this
is really what i want to do
at least for the foreseeable future
that what i love doing is going out and
finding
these stories that are
immensely significant
but have either
fallen by the wayside
never made made it to the headlines or
were dismissed or shoved under the rug
perhaps i mean i might sound paranoid
here but perhaps for you know
conspiratorial reasons who knows
um but i found that i love
the notion of finding these stories
and
and some of them at least in this case
are so fabulous
that you could hardly
come up with fiction that can outdo this
um
i mean i
will find out if i did it justice but if
i have done it justice then you'll agree
with me that it's so beautiful it's so
astounding
just in the way that it unfolded
that to have fictionalized it would have
been to diminish it
i also found that um
in in some great ways
um you know
there were several dozen of these
political assassinations that that had
taken place and and i only write about
one and that's because this one happened
quite in a magical way in a way
at the end
of the five years
did you receive
significant cooperation from the
survivors families and from the families
of those that
did not survive the incident
right
um
a friend of mine who's who's also a
writer and a journalist herself
read the earlier version of the
manuscript and said
that she was really touched and deeply
moved by
the quality of the interviews and
information that i'd gathered
and of course i could have fooled her
and said yes i'm a fantastic interviewer
and
it's they would only open up to me
but in truth
precisely because the story had not been
covered
or or i shouldn't say had not been
covered the story had been covered but
but from certain angles from from a
deeply political and legal angle
that
and and in pieces because it was a
five-year span so you know
one day there was a very exciting day at
the trial and there would be a big
article in the newspaper and then
two weeks later there would be something
else but never in one
big
kind of
tapestry of the full story in all of its
glory and
and because that had not happened i
think
all these people the survivors the
the widows the people who had lost loved
ones in there um we're waiting for
someone to show up so
i don't think it i
exercised any
fantastic skill to get them to talk i
think they they were waiting for years
for someone to show up and and talk um
and the rest of it was just on record
because you know the trial had
um had already concluded and and all the
material was there and there was an
archive
um that i simply
went to and
you know they were all fortunately
catalogued on shelves
otherwise it would have been impossible
to put together
i'm a little bit unsure of one thing uh
the part of the german cooperation from
the authorities
am i to understand that that
there was a hesitancy or
a lack of cooperation
from the authorities for a crime like
this committed in their own country i
mean i find that to be unusual
considering
you know it's a western european country
and the um
the general attitude of this type of a
thing taking place on their own soil
so i mean i can imagine that there's
german business interests that are
involved with iran that are probably
very strong interest but for something
like this that's that dramatic
that sounds to me to be something um
unexpected exactly not an expert on it
right but just from common knowledge yes
well you're right one would think based
on one what one knows about germany
about europe
about
just the standards of practice that this
should have been unusual this should
have been treated
as um as completely unacceptable and
crimes like this which had happened in
austria france
sweden
switzerland
italy
greece
united states and
they were
right argentina later on um they were
they were happening
and oftentimes
what would happen was that either they
were
um
if if the perpetrators were arrested
um
in in some cases they would not be
arrested you know either they were
really good and got away or sometimes
because of precisely business interests
that you refer to um the auth the
authorities would be a little slower
than usual in in apprehending them and
they would slip away
um there were a couple of cases where
they slipped away and in the case of
another assassination in 1989
in vienna austria
one of the perpetrators was apprehended
and two weeks later was put back on a
plane
and deported to tehran
and the authorities cited national
interests and said
because of our national interests we
will not prosecute this man
and and it is because of that
that
more crimes were happening
and in my view eventually
even though
from 1980 when when the first case
occurred until 1997 when the verdict
from this case was issued
there's a 17-year lapse
there is
a burgeoning or a gathering of momentum
of these assassinations precisely
because
they seem to be able to get away with it
because of trade interest because of
business interest and also because
given that the united states no longer
had an embassy in tehran because of the
hostage crisis of 1979 and because the
united states was no longer present had
a political or
any other interests uh
in iran
it had become sort of a
beacon of hope tehran as or or iran in
general as a place for europe to slip
into and for this balance of power
finally between europe and the united
states to to happen
uh within the middle east via this
foothold in in iran so they were so
there were diplomatic interests as well
as trade and business interests and by
1992 when this happens trade relations
between iran and germany are at a peak
and the germa the the iranians are
absolutely certain
that there is no way
the germans would
jeopardize those trade relations over a
silly trial
and so
what makes this story really fabulous
is that the germans precisely wanted to
do what iran had hoped
german
administer the german administration
politicians involved did want to make
the trial go away did want to make the
case go away but it just wouldn't
and so it's the process of how it
wouldn't go away
how it is that
two powers come together
to to
cover this up and yet it seems to go on
and take on a life of its own that makes
it really wonderful
yes please how has it changed you to
write this you said it's kind of changed
the course of your career that you were
a poet and then you wrote a memoir
and now you would like to do more books
of this genre so it must have had an
impact on you to write this
um
it hasn't i was thinking about what i
want to write next and i i have a couple
of ideas in fact i have
um planned one
that that is very exciting to me
um
the only thing it has changed um within
me is that i
once thought that i would like to try my
hand at fiction
but after this
i think there are so many great stories
that have gone untold
that if they are discovered and properly
told
by people who can have
proper access
proper knowledge because that you know i
i
was in a privileged position with this
story i mean i
being iranian or having been born and
raised in iran i
clearly
had access to a whole slew of things
that you know a non-iranian would have a
harder time getting at
um so i think there are there are
individuals there are individual writers
who are particularly positioned to do
certain stories and i think we owe it
um
not just to the public but to history
to
to literature
to rediscover these stories and show
what it is about them
that
beg
revisiting
i think i mean aside from the fact i
mean i keep talking about this as a
great story as a great story
but
in addition to the fact that it is a
great story
it's also a very very essential story
for
all of us today
who
want to understand what in the world
is going on with iran i mean it seems
like
the more we spend time
and i say we and the way that i'm using
here includes the white house to
ordinary americans who
are just well informed the more we spend
time learning about it reading about it
the less we understand it it seems like
a
like a terribly enigmatic place
and i think part of the reason
i don't find it enigmatic
i find it in part tragic but
but not
you know not so enigmatic
part of it is because
there are fundamental narratives that we
don't know about each other
there are certain fundamental stories
that we need to know
about each other
and i i believe that this is one of them
now you know
um
during each presidency of
in the united states we hear
you know iran is cast in
in a new light somehow it's always a
light a dark light but
but there is you know the angles kind of
change and all that
and we hear
uh sort of one one take on the country
um and yet it doesn't lead to
a greater comprehension to a greater
understanding or anything and i think
perhaps part of it has to do with the
fact that there are
really really
important narratives
that
we aren't telling
the outsiders you know that there are
insider stories that we pass on to each
other within the exile community within
within the community of iranians and we
don't manage to pass it on
and
and then
there are stories that somehow in
addition to being translated but also
need to be interpreted and passed on and
i think those are the kind of stories
that we even as human beings when we
start to
i don't know fall in love or become
friends
they're among the first things that we
exchange with each other you know where
did you grow up you know
who is you know what school did you go
to is there basic information um not
simply about the facts or or the data
of the location and the population of
the country but also the
fundamental emotions that
or fundamental events
that really changed the nation or shape
the nation and i think
it's it's for writers like me who
probably live in that overlapping space
between the two
cultures and countries to figure them
out and tell them
yes please
we shouldn't wait for a book of poetry
about murders
a book of poetry about murders
there's an idea
but i hope when you read it you find
that some passages are pretty poetic
thank you so much for coming
[Applause]
is there a non-fiction author or book
you'd like to see featured on book